J'ai toujours beaucoup aimé les films Marvel
Madame Web m'a beaucoup séduit salut
Cassie Web ce film est avant qu'elle ne se
retrouve dans un fauteuil roulant elle est hyper
intelligente et son plus grand super pouvoir
est son esprit Je savais qu'il allait
mourir Je l'ai vu
quand Cassie commence  pour expérimenter sa
Clairvoyance, elle pense qu'elle perd la
tête, vous êtes la seule à pouvoir changer
l'avenir. Madame Webb ne ressemble à aucun
autre super-héros quand vous pensez
à la façon dont Spider-Man vole dans les
airs ou à Venom quand il change, c'est tellement
mythique de  nous mais avec elle tout est
psychologique je peux voir le futur et j'ai
trouvé ça incroyablement excité d'
explorer essayons ça encore une fois ces
visions sont assez fragmentées car elle
ne voit rien clairement j'ai déjà vu
cet homme alors qui est-il Ezekiel
Sims  il était en Amazonie avec ma
mère juste avant sa mort Madame Web
rassemble ces quatre mots de super-héros
tu ne penses pas que ce soit bizarre
comme nous sommes tous
connectés c'est honnêtement comme la chose la moins
bizarre qui soit arrivée toute la journée la
Genèse et le  Début de ce qui va
devenir, vous montrez peut-être un
peu [Musique]